كتب مراسل صحيفه لومون في القدس لوي امبير
ان مقتل ثلاثه من الرهائن الاسرائيليين
لدى حماس عن طريق الخطا على يد الجيش
الاسرائيلي احيا مخاوف العائلات وادى الى
تظاهر المئات وسط تل ابيب وخارج مقر الجيش
لمطالبه الحكومه بالافراج عن الرهائن باي
ثمن وعلق المراسل ان حي الشجاعيه حيث قتل
الرهائن الثلاثه هو احد الاحياء الشرقيه
في غزه حيث تكبد الجيش الاسرائيلي اكبر
خسائره منذ
شهرين من جهته كتب رون بن ياشاي في مقال
راي بصحيفه دعوت احرونوت ان مقتل الرهائن
ليس ماساه فحسب بل هي وصمه عار ليس فقط
لان ثلاثه اسرائيليين قتلوا عن طريق الخطا
بيد الجيش الذي كان من المفترض ان ينقذهم
من الاسر ولكن لانها كانت ايضا حاله اطلاق
نار واضحه لقتل لاناس عزل ووفقا لتحقيقات
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان من الواضح تماما
انهم لم يشكلوا خطرا على القوه التي اطلقت
النار عليهم وازهق حياتهم حسب
الكاتب في صحيفه الجاردين قال الكاتب
جوناثان فريدلاند ان هناك طريقه واحده
للخروج من حرب غزه وان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يعرقلها لذلك
يجب على الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اجبار
نتنياهو على التنحي عن السلطه واوضح
فريدلاند ان نتنياهو يعارض الطريقه
الوحيده القابله للتطبيق للمضي قدما وهو
حل الدولتين ويعمل الان لمصلحته الشخصيه
فقط ويجب على الرئيس الامريكي انقاذ
اسرائيل من رئيس وزرائها
الحالي قالت صحيفه الفاينانشال تايمز ان
الولايات المتحده طلبت من اسرائيل خفض حده
الحرب في غزه في المستقبل القريب مع تزاي
الضغوط الداخليه على البيت الابيض جراء
ارتفاع عدد القتلى في قطاع غزه حسب
الصحيفه واشارت الى ان التدخل الامريكي
جاء في الوقت الذي حذر فيه مسؤولون
اسرائيليون كبار من ان هزيمه حماس ستستغرق
شهورا ووضع رؤيه لمستقبل غزه بعد الحرب
تختلف بشكل حاد عن الافكار التي طرحتها
واشنطن بما في ذلك سيطره اسرائيل الامنيه
الكامله على القطاع
[موسيقى]
ختاما قالت مجله نيوزويك ان الهجمات التي
نفذتها جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين اليمنيه
في مضيق باب المندب على السفن الاسرائيليه
والسفن الاخرى المتجهه الى اسرائيل ادت
الى قطع شريان حياه اقتصادي حاسم لها وسط
حربها المستمره ضد حماس في غزه ونقلت عن
نائب امين الاعلام في الجماعه نصر الدين
عامر ان هدفهم من العمليات واضح هو ادخال
المساعدات والغذاء والدواء الى
غزه